are you migrating to club what should
you migrate first stay tuned to find out
[Music]
welcome to cloud migration 101 where we
share migration tips and tricks I'm
Priyanka and I'm Kyle and in this
episode we'll walk you through the
process of choosing the first
application of migrate to Google cloud
let's say today I'm the head of
engineering at cloudy Corp we make
automated floodgates for water Mills as
you can imagine our infrastructure is
complicated with a large number of
applications and I'm not sure which
application to move first well let me
help demystify this process let's start
by saying all of your apps and what they
are yes so here are all our apps the
first thing to do is to group your
applications into categories all my
singles your applications multi-tier
applications databases and dev tools are
grouped together now awesome now we find
one common example in each category
something that does a good job of
representing the entire category for
this we will have to drill deeper into
what makes an app a good candidate for
being the first to migrate exactly and
there's a list of criteria that I
generally recommend all right let's go
through this list then a good first
application to migrate should be
something that's typical of your
existing workloads but nothing that's
business critical we want to use this
application to build a knowledge base
within our organization around how to
migrate applications to the cloud for
this reason we should not pick an app
that is extremely business critical but
we should also not pick an app that is
used to save few times a year try to
find a balance of moderately business
critical applications so it helps
increase the momentum of the migration
now the second criteria is that we want
an application that's managed by a
central team so it has support and
ideally has an application owner who
embraces innovation picking a
high-performance team that sits in the
main office with a proven history of
implementing modern dev practices DevOps
and sre can be a good candidate if these
apps have leadership sponsors and clear
goals that would be perfect now the
third criteria is that we want to try
and find something that's relatively
standalone with a low number of network
security and application dependencies
and also doesn't need any code
refactoring
to move to the cloud stateless apps
would be great because they don't
require any data migration or an app
that only needs configuration changes
but no code changes next the data
storage requirements should be
relatively small if your application has
petabytes of storage probably shouldn't
use that as a first mover this is mainly
because we don't want to start off with
an edge case by picking an app that is
not representative of the most of the
other apps the application should also
not be subjected to any complicated
compliance or licensing challenges make
sure the licensing terms are clear check
if the license allows you to run the app
in the cloud or not you may also have
specific compliance requirements for
example in some countries the customer
has the right to decide where to store
their data for these reasons we
recommend such apps not be the first
ones that you migrate and last but not
least we want an application that can
afford a cut of her window if the
application has to stay up a hundred
percent of the time it is not a great
candidate for your first mover
application your teams are going to be
learning with the first mover and we
want to be able to provide them a
cushion where if they make a mistake
it's not detrimental to your business
since an application like batch
processing can tolerate a longer
downtime than the customer facing apps
it makes sense to pick batch processing
service over the e-commerce apps
assuming it meets other criterias we
discussed earlier exactly now let's try
and apply this to our applications at
cloudy core so here's a landscape of
applications we already grouped the apps
based on categories among these apps
what are some of your high performance
teams
well inventory payment SAS and mobile
apps document database sequel database
and CI tools are some of our high
performance apps and out of those which
would require refactoring or migration
has major dependencies that it would
require SAS and mobile apps along with
sequel database have dependencies and
may require refactoring but others are
fairly independent okay
what about serious edge cases sequel
database is huge and also won't lead to
a ton of learning that can apply to
other apps
except for maybe another sequel database
that is internal so that could be a
later migration great do any of these
have licensing concerns no but there are
some data compliance things that we need
to take care of around users and data
in EU for our SAS application so we
cannot start with that okay and which of
these apps can afford a decent cut of a
window CI tools an inventory service
can't afford a cut a war window for sure
payment service and sequel database has
to be hundred percent available all the
time so those will be a no go for the
first phase well with that you have the
list of apps that you want to migrate
first start with the inventory app learn
from that apply it to the mobile app CI
tool the sequel database and do that in
sequence remember it's really beneficial
to start small move a very simple
application first and learn a bunch
about how you're going to run your
larger and more complex applications on
Google Cloud and by using this approach
you'll set your business up for a
successful migration to Google Cloud so
today we learned how to decide what to
migrate first we started by grouping our
apps into categories and then apply
these different categories to make the
right choice if you are in the process
of migration don't forget to Like and
subscribe because we don't want you to
miss any episode of this cloud migration
101 series